let's speak now if we can to the uh
ambassador or the ukrainian ambassador
to the united kingdom of adam
prischteiko ambassador great to have you
on the program this morning um i just
wonder if we can we can start with the
the military efforts that are continuing
to be made there is an awful lot of
disinformation that is flying around at
this moment in the crisis and and
largely coming from the russian side can
we put a number
on the number of russian soldiers that
have been killed as a result of their at
war with ukraine i've seen the numbers
which our official number is more than
14 000 people already the united states
estimating around
910 russians are actually reducing
obviously to a couple of thousands of
these people dead
how have you been able to achieve that i
mean certainly vladimir putin thought it
would be a simple matter of mobilizing
on the border heading into ukraine where
they would be welcomed as liberators as
heroes clearly that hasn't happened i
believe he's miscalculated a couple of
things first of all that we are not just
starting to fight we've been fighting
with him and with his proxy for eight
years so our forces are sort of battle
hardened at the same time what we also
have that we have just defended our own
land that's what he mistake that he
still believes that we are the same
people we have our lantern we have our
direction to go that's different from
what he has for us
it does fuel however the russian
russian tactics have have changed
significantly in the past few days the
advances that they've made have come to
a halt they appear to be regrouping
particularly in areas like around the
capital and so on but the artillery
bombardment and the far power from the
air continues to smash cities
including but not limited to maripo
you're right they're using ships from
the black sea they're using the uh air
and helicopters from occupied crimea to
get us and most of the rockets just sent
to beautiful cities like here like like
ideas so they are threatening yes right
in big cities like kharkivan cave
so how then do we do we bring an end to
the violence we understand of course
that there have been negotiations taking
place there was a call from your
president to have face-to-face talks
that doesn't appear to happen between
the leaders obviously but but do you see
a solution a negotiated solution to what
is happening in ukraine and if so what
will you have to concede
we believe there are two ways one of the
negotiations which also different
channels and all of them are working the
turks israeli helping us but we also
have our own negotiations on the border
between ukraine and belarus and this is
very technical and very painful
negotiations they've been doing for four
weeks already but what we can do at the
same time we can actually you know
defend ourselves with everything we have
and everything we are receiving from
nations like you and this is helping
that's why we are so effective that's
why we can burn so many tanks because we
have enough enough firepower to stop
these tanks it's not enough to repel
them from our territory yet but we are
working there just on just on the
question of enough fire power the the
reports that have been uh circulating
the past 24 hours suggesting that
actually such has been the tempo of the
ukrainian military activity that you are
beginning to to start to see a need for
more assistance from the west again when
it comes to armaments i mean is that the
case are you running out of weaponry
no not that much we we don't have enough
it didn't have enough in the first place
so running out of weaponry that's that's
we'll be seeing in the in the week to
come
because tomorrow presidency will talk to
nato the whole nato we will see how can
we replenish our stocks and what we can
have much longer range and stronger than
everything here we have enough weapons
to stop tanks immediately when they're
approaching to us but to clear out our
land we have to have something with a
much
greater distance yeah i mean just just
in terms of the the humanitarian cost of
all of this the longer those
bombardments go on the long the greater
the number of civilians innocent
civilians
will be dead as a result of all of this
just give us an idea of what what the
situation is like in in mariopol itself
at the moment we've all seen the
pictures there doesn't appear to be very
much of the city left frankly used to be
four hundred thousand cities very resort
like like brighton on a beach of very
shallow very warm silvers off where
mostly kids would go for the resorts
with their parents now it's more more or
less nothing what we're trying to
achieve we're trying to withdraw as many
civilians as we can unfortunately the
situation is not good the people are
lacking basic foods sometimes even water
but these people are very resilient
they're trying to to to stay where they
are we have troops within the city
they're fighting really furiously and
this is veterans of the eight years were
they know how to fight and they're
putting up a real fight if you see the
picture how russian tanks are burning
just coming through city that's what
what is happening there yeah you i mean
you don't have to to be a military
expert to have been impressed by the
fortitude that has been displayed by the
ukrainian people in the face of a
russian invasion and war at the same
time the strategy of attrition which
vladimir putin has instituted the mass
the wholesale destruction of urban areas
massive civilian casualties you can be
the strongest ukrainian in the world but
after a while that is going to have a
debilitating event on ukrainian morale
surely i understand what he's trying to
achieve he that's his tactic you know to
soften our negotiation position but just
killing our own people and besieging
these cities that this is this barbaric
sort of approach that's something he was
so proud of being from saint peter's
book in leningrad that the city was
besieged for more than two years two
years during world war ii and that's
coming with this proud
lingard
dweller he's doing the same to ukrainian
cities this is something very difficult
to you know to even calculate to
understand
just give us an idea then of of what it
is that ukraine would would like to see
from the west obviously the nato meeting
is pending but particularly as regards
the united kingdom it does feel that the
munitions the skill set that we had
previously exported to ukraine all of
that has proved very very useful indeed
you i don't see anything any limits here
in cooperation with you that that's you
know i'm very proud to be right here in
this capital we have everything we have
weapons we have support political
support we have financial support with
at the time when needed we have been
food being sent even the food the simple
bags and the boxes will be sent to
ukrainians everything we can come with
with refugees every every every aspect
of our war right now on our defense
that's been supported and held by by the
uk
i do want to get your view because
there's been an awful lot of speculation
in this country by britain's rather than
ukrainians about the way in which boris
johnson's word to the conservative
conference at the weekend would have
been interpreted by ordinary ukrainians
i wonder we'll just we'll just play it
first just to remind our viewers exactly
what he said but it was
an allusion to an a to a comparison
let's play
it's the instinct of the people of this
country
like the people of ukraine
to choose freedom every time
when the british people voted for brexit
in such large numbers i don't believe it
because they were remotely hostile to to
foreigners
it's because they wanted to be free
to do things differently and for this
country to be able to run itself
the prime minister there and many people
domestically thought that i was fairly
crass a comparison between you know a
vote to leave a political and economic
union and you and your countrymen
picking up arms to repel a russian
invasion what did you make of what the
prime minister said i believe i was
sitting at the
front row when i was listening to it i
didn't see that this reaction is coming
because what we heard in the room and i
were i heard myself that's actually we
are fighting for our freedom the freedom
to do what the nation wants to do if you
wanted to leave the european union
that's your own decision sovereign
decision we respect it we'd like you to
be in in the european union but we
respect this decision if we wanted to
leave something as a soviet union
we had to have a right and look at the
differences you believe you have
problems with the european union when
you left it's not a problem if you
compare to what we have with russians
when we left the soviet union they came
to kill us for this decision
i wonder what you make of of vladimir
putin at the moment and a number of
people have felt comfortable calling him
a war criminal we've heard from across
the atlantic accusations that he's been
participating in acts of genocide
actually the question i wish to ask you
is what do you think vladimir putin's
mental state is at the moment i believe
that he is delusional now
he was a very reasonable man in his own
way i had the privilege a couple of
times to defend ukrainian positions
sometimes it was with his with his
people and himself personally so i
understand what he thinks he doesn't see
ukrainians as a nation not just what he
was told on many many different
occasions but he just you can see by
conversing with him he despises you he
don't believe that you're on the same
level with him because he's almost sort
of off of russia and everything who are
you talking to him that's the mistake he
made and he made me say for the whole
nation not for the humanity see i i
suppose the question that follows that
is given given your assessment of of the
man the way in which he operates is is
there any way that the violence will
come to an end in ukraine whilst he
remains in the kremlin you know it's
very difficult to believe and so so so
little uh can be said and so a few
people believe but we're actually
winning we can't win with your support
with your assistance we can actually
turn the tide and for this once in a
while we can actually resolve the
situation we don't want to kill russians
or russia itself they will survive what
is happening here this regime might come
to end
define then victory what what does
victory look like because to my mind
russian troops standing five meters the
other side of the ukrainian border that
that doesn't look like victory to me
not to me either i would like to be in
something which would allow us to have
guarantees like like nato that's why
putin is going so against net because he
knows if he miscalculated now he can
come regroup and come later we have to
do something which will allow ukraine to
feel itself safe something we hope to
have after budapest when we signed the
agreement to give out the nuclear
weapons it didn't work so i don't want
to sign any other piece of paper it
won't work either there will be any
number of people watching at this this
morning ambassador who have perhaps
donated food parcels who have perhaps
donated some of their money who are
perhaps even preparing themselves to
open their doors to to your fellow
countrymen and women who maybe will be
arriving here very shortly i wonder if
you've got a message um for the british
people this morning i have a message for
them and i i know that i will be able to
bring this message also in london this
saturday when i will see the crowds of
people with the mayor of london we just
want to thank thank you and you know
people will do it much better than
myself those people who would come here
and feel the worms and in kindness and
response from from the whole uk they
will feel and they will bring this
message what i can tell you that we will
survive and you will have a new friend
on other sides of the of the european
continent we don't have many things in
our history we are starting to build our
new relations
adam bristek great to have you in the
studio this morning thank you so much
for joining us